Nick asks do you think that Facebook is
still effective even though it's pay to
play model and throttling Nick I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
what I've been screaming about for the
last hundred days but it's called
Facebook dark posts google it watch it
on YouTube bunch of people show you how
to use it not only do I think it's
effective I actually think right this
second as I tape the show Facebook is
the best direct selling marketing
platform in the world think about what I
just said google adwords phenomenal by
rebate retargeted banner exchange on
these ads on the exchange incredible
Facebook dark posts where did the
organic reach come from in other places
you didn't build a website and like
we're mad at Google if you weren't the
first result for a term you recognize
that it treated you the way it treated
you based on the quality of what you
were executing really no different than
Facebook plenty of people getting tons
of organic sure there's some twinkling
of the tools but that's their algorithm
no different than google you don't get
organic free reach from an email
marketing campaign that you spend money
on buying the email list or on banner
ads or on anything else you do in
marketing and so because it started as
an organic only platform and people
treated like email and you thought
everybody who was following you would
see it doesn't mean that the emotion
that that went away doesn't mean that it
isn't great as a matter of fact Facebook
has never been a better product I just
believe it I mean I don't know what else
to really say